[Music]
from the company that knows you like
star wars so they put a little star wars
on the star wars hub so you can watch
star wars before the next star wars
comes out comes what any responsible
content factory would do and outsources
the job to asia in these non-canon
japanese short films that would all make
for a better movie trilogy than the one
we just got somehow palpatine returned
and yes i'm including the furry episode
in fact especially the furry episode
here are all nine animated shorts from
star wars visions
from the studio that's probably going to
make optimus prime a shogun next comes a
general grievous level circle jerk of
influences in this kurosawa influence
star wars influenced by the star wars
most influenced by kurosawa again it's
like poetry so if they rhymed where a
ronin battles lucy lou for the fate of a
small feudal village but only after his
droid gets hurt he couldn't give a
before that
how dare you bedroid was wearing a hat
ronin holiday
in a world where the most popular music
on the planet is called jizz prepare for
the only genre that's even less
appealing
mid-2000s pop punk in this extremely
straightforward story about a band that
gets broken up by chibi boba fett and
immediately reunites because any more
story would take time away from joseph
gordon-levitt singing
see this is what happens when an anime
doesn't get 8 minutes of opening credits
they just drop it into the episode
blink 2187
get ready for an episode that feels like
it was inspired by the last jedi why you
like it i swear featuring more neon than
a batman forever street gang that shows
off what's possible when you go all
anime no breaks with the visuals but
still honors the prequel trilogy by
having horrible stilted dialogue kyber
crystal
such beauty such power
this energy will be a beacon of hope for
the galaxy
bravo allison brie you act you act as
hard as you can
and evil twins
when a village is threatened by raiders
wait didn't we see this one already oh
different village okay when another
village is threatened by raiders it will
take one masterless jedi teaming up with
an anti-massacre it doesn't suit you
that mask to help two orphans link their
majinas
by slicing up imperial scum with a
katana saber and some sweet tactical
high heel shoes wait didn't we see a
lady force user in heels already
is that so they always have the high
ground
wedding crashers
witness a short that packs so much world
building imagination and likeable
characters into 20 minutes you won't
even care that they ran out of
creativity for the names greetings my
name is ethan as a young apprentice gets
trapped in a temple full of sid who
wants to steal her custom lightsabers
even though all you have to do to get
one is download the saber pass app the
week before you go to the planet then
sign up using the saber magic system to
book your sabers vacation so that when
you do arrive at the temple all you need
to do is check in get your saber band
log the qr code on saberpass then report
to the lightsaber store add 300 credits
to your mysaver account and get in the
two-hour reserve queue simple
my saber totoro
from the team that made space dandy
[Music]
uh all right comes baby's first star war
about a droid who was built to sit in a
small room and do math but also given
feelings of love boredom and frustration
because star wars loves to remind us
that droids are slaves
your name is toby
pinocchio
from the people who also made the psycho
one about the evil twins comes the star
warsification of a clint eastwood movie
as a salty old jedi warrior sends his
assistant of a dang mountain to face a
sith while he hangs out a base camp too
make sure he didn't double back uh-huh
that ends with the jedi pretending to be
dead then ganging up in an old man while
they're distracted
this is also supposed to be heroic
elder abuse
blast off to the zootopia system for 20
minutes that will delight everyone from
anime fans to star wars fans to furries
and yes i'm aware that being a fan of
one significantly raises your chances of
being the other two in this heartwarming
saga of a father having to decide which
of his daughters will inherit the family
lightsaber the tiny tomb with a heart of
gold or the evil human who uses her own
blood as eyeliner do you want pink eye
cause that's the other way to get pink
eye
bunny heist
from still japan but with a few pieces
of african flair comes a really annoying
road trip across the planet of the tiny
mouths in a classic tale of how when a
jedi falls in love everything turns to
yep even an anime they're creepy sexless
monks who are only allowed to play with
their own lightsabers
literally star wars visions
starring
when you all copied off the same kid for
your test i got a bad feeling about this
you have a bad feeling about this i have
a bad feeling about this you've got a
bad feeling about this i've got a bad
feeling about this and more crystal talk
than a white girl's apartment if you use
the power of the kyber crystal the
crystal is the core of the lightsaber
crystal crystals crystal crystal
crystals crystal crystals
[Music]
weed content
okay how is there not a short where luke
skywalker is the principal at a high
school for french maids i figure at
least one anime studio would have had
that idea
it's a me chris pratio
i will not fear fear is the mind killer
well it's one for the money two for the
show three to get ready now go
cat go
do the elderly where boxers or briefs
depends